the first person to take a photograph of  themselves was probably equally by R the  very first selfies he took in 1837 are  completely lost but we still have this  one from 1840. it's technically a selfie  and it's also the first staged  Photograph by our pioneered the  invention of Photography but he was  tricked into losing credit he and Louis  De Guerre both independently discovered  ways of taking and developing  photographs but a friend of deguerre  convinced Bayard to keep his own process  secret a little bit longer that gave  daguerre just enough time to announce  and demonstrate his process first and  get all the credit to express the depth  of his angst bayar took this photograph  of himself in which he appears to be  dead he called it self-portrait as a  drowned man and on the back he wrote Mr  bayar has drowned himself because of  Injustice so 163 years before Myspace  there was this the world's first emo  selfie